hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
january 18 2021
2021 it's a huge day
huge week it's a huge week in america
um for those around the world if you
don't realize it the nfl playoffs
we're in the middle of it uh
and by the way there's gonna be a
transfer of power uh the bills
your buffalo bills who would have thunk
it
16 [ __ ] games 17 games ago who would
have thunk
that the perennial basement dwellers
or middle of the pack of the afc east
would win the afc east
win the first round in the playoffs wait
did they play that they played last week
again i already forget who the [ __ ] they
beat and uh
going up against the ravens and uh you
know what i was with verzi and we sort
of did it because we got our first
podcast uh we're gonna record it on
wednesday
and um i had my picks
and this is what i picked i picked the
buffalo bills to beat the ravens even
though i kind of thought the ravens
were gonna win i was just i just kind of
went with my heart i wanted the
i wanted the bills to win all right
and then green bay versus the rams i
pick green bay
then casey this is against the spread
too casey
against the browns i took the browns
i thought the browns had a shot uh they
definitely covered it we get like 10 10
and a half i forget
and then uh tampa bay versus the saints
i mean i'm a long time patriots fan so
you know who i took
you know i took i took the saints
i hadn't watched the uh the buccaneers
since like mid
november and they looked sloppy and then
i started thinking ah that bruce ahrens
guy he's a [ __ ] players coach he's
walking around with the kangol hat
still you know that teacher that was
still trying to be cool
and be friends with like the high school
kids
sort of creepy you know talking to the
cheerleaders a little too much in the
[ __ ] class you know
um i thought it was one of those deals
so i'm like yeah ain't gonna [ __ ] win
with the goddamn player coach
and uh the [ __ ] was i thinking betting
against tom brady
it was weird my money was on the saints
but i was rooting for
tampa bay if that makes any sense so um
i went three and one so let's let's do
oh billy's breakdown of the games
where i don't know anybody's names or
whatever um
i don't know anybody's names you guys
saw the [ __ ] games let's just talk a
couple of highlights here
the [ __ ] cleveland browns
i got to tell you something man they
were driving me
[ __ ] crazy
during that game because i knew that
with the right game plan
straight up forget about my homes
getting choked out or whatever happened
to him
um they could beat kansas city kansas
city is a very
beatable team um
and as much as everybody's blowing them
going like this is the greatest offense
all of these weapons well i've never
seen a [ __ ] thing like this before
that uh
i it's like the fifth incarnation of one
of these these
unbelievable offenses that nobody can
[ __ ] beat
all right remember the 2008 patriots
oh my god nobody's going to stop them
giants
right uh remember the [ __ ] greatest
show on turf oh my god i gotta score a
thousand [ __ ] points patriots
beat him in the super bowl
i remember the [ __ ] uh the bills when
they first came out their first year the
running gun
they were gonna [ __ ] destroy the
giants the giants beat him
i remember an 86 [ __ ] elway and all
his receivers no one's going to beat him
the giants beat him
and i'll be saying oh the [ __ ] choice
no bill belichick
bill belichick at 86 and 90 and then uh
tom coughlin in 2008 if you got a great
coach and they know what the [ __ ]
they're doing
the cleveland browns had the
[ __ ] team to beat the goddamn
chiefs
and what did they do they started
playing chiefs football
like everybody does chiefs get the ball
they go right down the [ __ ] field
give them the o right there fred
and make it seven or nothing and
everybody gets out of their game plan
that offense is so [ __ ] scary that
everybody goes like oh [ __ ]
we gotta throw the ball if we're gonna
keep if we're gonna beat this team we
need to score [ __ ] 38 points
meanwhile the cleveland browns have the
best offensive line in the afc if not
the nfl
and the best one-two punch kareem hunt
and nate chubb running game they should
have been running a game when you run
into a [ __ ] offense like the kansas
city chiefs what do you do
you slow it down you slow the [ __ ]
game down you don't start playing to
that [ __ ] pace
and that's what the [ __ ] they did in the
first half it drove me up the [ __ ]
wall
they should have been running on first
down and wearing down
the defensive line to the kansas city
chiefs which is good but it's not great
so come the third quarter you start
running downhill and old [ __ ] patrick
mahomes
and and tyreke hill and kelsey and all
those [ __ ] monsters are standing on
the sidelines
that's what the [ __ ] you do that's what
the [ __ ] you do you beat a team
that scores 38 [ __ ] points a game by
beating them like 20 to 17
because you had the [ __ ] ball the
whole time
all right remember the [ __ ] uh uh
think about all those those games that i
just mentioned about those high powered
offenses they all got beat on low
[ __ ] scoring
games because the other team had the
[ __ ] ball
that's why that's why and they didn't do
it they were [ __ ] throwing the ball
by the way
baker mayfield made some amazing [ __ ]
plays so only imagine if they had beaten
up their [ __ ]
defensive line and only imagine
when when mahomes was out of the game
what the [ __ ] could have happened and
instead
their line was still fresh
i don't think kareem hunt had a [ __ ]
touch in the whole first half it was
unbelievable
now having said that you got to take
your hat off to the [ __ ]
defending champs that they could lose
their tom brady
and have that hanky guy come in where
the hell his [ __ ] name is
um and that guy got it done i mean that
is a championship team when they can
lose their best guy
and still beat a really really good
cleveland browns team um
so hats off to them but i will say this
the bills
if they do what the [ __ ] i just said
because they have the defense that can
beat kansas city
kansas city is not the [ __ ] i'm so
[ __ ] sick of everybody jerking off
these high-powered offenses i remember
that whole year the patriots were
undefeated
you know from october on keith robinson
was going i don't like their defenses
like i don't like their defense either
we were very very beatable
um as far as like
just our def our defense wasn't that
good and and we started
what year was that i figured what the
[ __ ] what the hell happened what scandal
that
[ __ ] scandal was that one i think i
can't even remember was that the spygate
one
that was spygate yeah that was that was
spygate so then we had to show although
this is what we could have been doing we
started running up the score and
everybody like [ __ ] pete carroll at
usc
so then everybody we started playing
playoff games so we were getting [ __ ]
beat down
everybody was going extra hard against
us by the time we got to the [ __ ]
playoffs
you know we we were not a balanced team
um but anyway
uh i really wanted the browns bills
afc championship game i was really
rooting for that i love a [ __ ]
underdog but i'm also i'm not a hater i
also love the kansas city chiefs and
um i love that they still play in that
old [ __ ] stadium
and that you know the chiefs have not
held that [ __ ] city hostage
and make them build this big stupid-ass
[ __ ] stadium
arrowhead stadium i think is the best
stadium in the [ __ ] league i hate all
the new stadiums
you know where the fans are like a
million [ __ ] miles away and they got
some sushi chef on the [ __ ] vip
mezzanine [ __ ] level whatever the
hell it is
um and i really think it's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that the and really one of the things i
hate the most about the nfl is that they
make
cities pay for their [ __ ] football
stadiums
i mean i mean that's like so that's like
right up there with like
churches not having to pay taxes
it's like who enough you don't have to
pay taxes why
because you're claiming you know what
happens after we die you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh and meanwhile you're out there
raping kids
kicking your [ __ ] chair for the
potholes you [ __ ]
um but i believe bob kraft did not hold
us
he didn't hold us hostage either but
everybody else you know when i went to
[ __ ] indianapolis
right why are you going to indianapolis
bill uh when i went out there
the hoosier dome the city had still not
even paid for
and jim irsay that [ __ ] steaming pile
of [ __ ] [ __ ] of a human being
um that for some reason espn listens to
him like he's a [ __ ] war hero
over the years uh that steaming pile of
[ __ ] made them [ __ ] pay for the uh
lucas oil field
lucasfuckin oilfield so anyway it was a
great [ __ ] game
um and even with all the mistakes i
thought that kansas city made by not
utilizing their running game
and beating down a very beatable kansas
city defense
um they kind of played into their hand
and it's going to be really interesting
to see what the bills do
i'm working on my game plan are you guys
making that joke that i [ __ ] look
like that guy
uh bill mcdermott bill mc bill mcburman
um what was i going to say uh
i think that that is going to be a uh
a great great game provided if mahomes
is playing but like um i agreed with
what that whatever that bald dude's
guy's name is on the uh
i feel like i should know him because
i'm bald too um
i think we should like stick together
some dumb [ __ ] uh the guy
on on the one with terry bradshaw and
howie long that one
the fox the fox one um he was saying
that he thought that
mahomes got uh choked out which is great
news for kansas city fans because then
he wouldn't have a concussion
um and i know it's weird because he
didn't really see him get hit in the
head
he just kind of got his head like
twisted around with his jersey or
something was that guy was like pulling
on him
and um i remember when i saw uh
what's his face choke out uh
steve oh um
oh my god what the [ __ ] his name the
one the greatest ufc champ called chuck
liddell
when he choked out steve stevo let him
put him in a chokehold
he he [ __ ] had him in it for like he
was like .5 seconds and stevo was just
out like a light
so i think like accidentally that's kind
of what happened
with mahomes and every fighter i've ever
heard was saying i'd rather get choked
out than knocked out
um as far as like with the damage that
it does so if that is the case then kc
should be right as reign to play the
buffalo bills
um
as much as i was disappointed with the
browns it was it was
really great to watch a championship
team you basically saw a team that knows
how to win
and another team that needs to learn how
to win was basically it
um so anyway uh
and i think at this point baker mayfield
has proven all of his naysayers wrong
with some of those [ __ ] throws that
he made
where he was putting the ball um i
really like that guy
all right tampa bay tom brady the tom
brady buccaneers
beat the new orleans saints and i gotta
look this guy up i have to look this guy
up who the [ __ ]
is number 45
the tampa bay buccaneers it was like
marshawn lynch was playing [ __ ]
defense
uh tampa bay devin white
aged 22 237 pounds oh lsu guy
he's six feet tall when the first
when he made one of those picks i was
like is that guy your [ __ ] safety
because he didn't look that tall but he
was [ __ ] jacked
then i saw him lining up he yeah inside
linebacker
oh my god what a force of nature that
kid is
so tom brady matches um
i believe his uh
his favorite quarterback growing up joe
montana where he went to another team
and got him to the afc
uh uh a conference championship game
he also with that victory yesterday
um now has twice as many playoff wins as
the next hall of fame quarterback which
is joe montana joe montano's got 16.
tom brady has 32. i mean it's just
[ __ ] unbelievable
and and still you know people will
[ __ ]
i don't somehow [ __ ] on the guy oh he's
a system guy but blah blah blah now he's
in tampa bay
he still [ __ ] wins still still they
will still try and come up with
something
but um i think the uh
it's looking like the near future
um the heirs to try to knock off kansas
city
are cleveland and buffalo who the [ __ ]
would ever think
that you would say that and i think the
bills um
there's no reason why they can't go into
kansas city and beat that team
um and i know a lot of people in kansas
city think i'm just hating on the chiefs
i'm not
i'm not i just i you know i root for a
[ __ ] underdog i just do
um your [ __ ] drought ended you just
won one last year i don't i don't
feel bad for you [ __ ] barbecue eating
sons of [ __ ] out there
um but having said that i love the
chiefs i love the uniforms
i love the whole story of how you guys
ended up there
you guys want to hear a little story
here's how kansas said he ended up in
kansas city
uh there was a group of [ __ ]
millionaires
all white guys of course way back in the
day
how the sister worked um they started a
football league a rival football league
the afl
started in 1960. the nfl as always
laughed it off the same way they laughed
off the uh
the all-american football conference and
said that that was a joke of a league
and that the competition wasn't same
level right and then what happened the
cleveland browns
joined the nfl when the all-american
football conference ended and in their
first year
they won under paul brown they won the
[ __ ] nfl title
and then they went to the championship
game every [ __ ] year from 1950 i
believe to 1955.
50 51 for two three four five yes six
years in a [ __ ] row after winning all
four titles
the all-american football conference
they won in 1950 against the la rams
which was significant because they used
to be the cleveland rams
not only did they win they beat the uh
the former nfl representation
in cleveland then they lost to the rams
at 51
and uh back-to-back years to bobby lane
with the with the lions
and then in 55 54 and 55
they won and then otto graham retired
the first tom brady
right i don't know why i had to go into
all of that i just do it so i can
remember
then i believe the giants wanted 56.
57 was the lions 58 59 was the cold 60s
was the eagles
you guys don't want me to do this do you
61-62 was the packers 63 was the bears
then the browns at 64
65 66 67 was green bay these are nfl
titles
and then the colts one is 68 and then
the vikings won one in 69
and then the merger happened um so
anyway
um they start up the afl in 1960 so once
again the nfl's laughing oh yeah it's a
it's a mickey mouse [ __ ] league the
same way they always did
with the all-american football league
and this was also the third incarnation
of the afl
there was an uh uh american football
league this was the third time
someone had used that name so
um as the nfl was making
fun of the afl they made a couple of
moves
to try and sabotage the chances of the
afl
all right because they you know
they saw what the af the what the
all-american football conference did so
they're like that's you know publicly
say that they're a [ __ ] joke and then
let's do a couple things all right so
this is what they did
the minnesota vikings a lot of people
don't know this were
an afl team um
so what the nfl did was they went
to the owners of the minnesota vikings
and say hey rather than joining the afl
you want to just join the nfl
and they were like uh [ __ ] yeah and they
did
right so they took one of the afl's
teams that's the first thing they did
they took a team that could have earned
some revenue for this new league
and god knows that's what you need cash
and then
uh lamar was it lamar hunt why am i
thinking now lamar lundy
see kansas city chiefs
original owner
kansas city chiefs it was lamar hunt
yeah so he had the deepest pockets
out of all the owners in the afl and he
had a team
called the dallas texans all right
so he was going to be in dallas they had
the red and white uniforms and they had
the state of texas on the side
of their helmet really cool [ __ ] you
know basic bare bones
logo so what the nfl did was okay so
they took one team and then the next
move they made they were like okay
who's the richest owner who can [ __ ]
hang on the longest
um in the afl and it was
uh lamar hunt with the dallas texans so
what they did was they awarded dallas an
nfl franchise which was
the dallas cowboys tom landry came over
from the giants
became their first head coach and the
rest is history so
now if you're living in dallas you're
all excited you have two professional
football teams
and where are you gonna go you're gonna
go to the afl league with a bunch of
no-name players
or are you gonna go to dallas and watch
the new
expansion team get the [ __ ] kicked out
of him by the cleveland browns but you
get to watch jim brown
the greatest running back of all time
arguably
run all over your new team so they split
the gate at least
in half there so lamar hunt
ended up having to move the dallas
texans to kansas city and the kansas
uh the kansas the dallas texans became
the kansas city chiefs they kept the
colors
and then they went to the uh the
arrowhead on the side
and um it's all been good it's all been
good until uh
did you guys catch at the end of the
camp when the kansas city one did you
catch the guy dressed up as santa claus
doing the tomahawk chalk
doing though
that was that really annoyed me as a
stand-up comedian
the fact that if i did a joke about
transgendered people i would be in a lot
of [ __ ] trouble
but this [ __ ] white dude could stand
there
doing the hollywood version
of native american music
[Music]
dressed as santa claus
i mean the guy was begging to get
canceled
not only does he not get canceled
they're showing him on tv i can't i
don't know how many times i got to make
this point i will continue to make this
point
doing the tomahawk chop and acting like
you're honoring native american culture
when you're singing the song that white
people came up when they wouldn't use
even use native american actors and they
would put [ __ ] white people in
rouge to act like they were [ __ ] uh
native american and to be singing that
stupid song that some white guy came up
with
right same thing with the drummer
that's not how they play drums all of
that [ __ ] is hollywood
doing the tomahawk chop would be the
equivalent if the germans won
in world war ii okay
finish their genocide of jews and then
at every soccer event they went oh
eve oh eve
be like we're honoring the jewish people
we murdered
um i still don't understand that one
with all the [ __ ] you know you got
female reps with by the way they they
brought
female refs in at the right [ __ ] time
i as much as i make fun of the nfl
you know and [ __ ] on them with their
[ __ ] holding cities hostage
making making them buy stadiums
pay for the stadiums um they did the
right thing
you know when they sit there you know if
any feminist ever goes
really it took until 2000 whatever to
get a female reffin
it's like hey sweetheart
hey spider legs there let me tell you
something
if we brought these women in back when i
was coming up watching football oh my
god this [ __ ] people would have said to
him
oh my god what do you want your [ __ ]
period
would have been [ __ ] brutal it would
have been brutal so
they basically needed um
social media and cell phone cameras
is really what you know had to happen
where where people would be held
accountable and everybody would just rat
on everybody
because they wanted not because they
gave a [ __ ] about the cause because they
wanted to get a bunch of hits so then
they could become an influencer
you know what i mean and then [ __ ]
ride a tricycle listening to fleetwood
mac
how many guys how many people ripped off
that dude on the skateboard the coolest
dude ever
um anyway uh
and i'm actually really like uh
i noticed yesterday when i was watching
football like uh
that the women on the sidelines like i
don't even notice it anymore
okay as a recovered meat head that's
actually a big moment for me
moving forward as a human being
i still think i still think though that
women
are are their approach
is is still incredibly [ __ ] stupid
um as far as their and i don't buy
that they they but they're still not
organized and they're still not helping
each other out and if you don't believe
that
all you have to do is see how hard
they're trying to work for the [ __ ]
nfl
while they all completely ignore the
wnba
i mean that [ __ ] goddamn league
should be
jam-packed with women losing their
[ __ ] minds
face painted and all of that so those
women down there
can make the salaries of
of what the guys do but no [ __ ] women
show up
there's like 2 300 people a thousand
people at every [ __ ] game whatever is
at the game
and i'm not even saying all of them are
paid it is [ __ ] ridiculous you are
basically
every [ __ ] game saying
that women professional athletes um
are not worth watching women are saying
that
by not going to those [ __ ] games
and and this is the thing i want to hear
from feminists on that one
because you are so [ __ ] your plan of
attack was like watching the cleveland
browns not running the ball in the first
[ __ ] half
as much as they should have um it's the
same thing for you guys to [ __ ] sit
there
and and try to worm your way in as
sideline reporters
and and leave all of those professional
women athletes what do they make like 30
grand a year
if you packed that [ __ ] place out you
were creating
the nba literally made a [ __ ] league
for women and you don't even go to it
[ __ ] unbelievable unfucking
believable and then while with your dumb
[ __ ] hashtags
it's unreal what is that what is it
about them that they just can't go off
and do their own [ __ ] thing
they're always overlooking what we're
doing you know what it is it's because
men we're just more fun we're a better
goddamn type
women don't even want to go down and
hang out with a bunch of women
[Music]
look this is just the message that i'm
getting
maybe i'm not a recovered meathead
anyway uh plowing ahead i think
i think there was a good point to be
made somewhere in there
um all right let's uh
let's go uh let's all go to the lobby
all right let me read some um some of
the interviews
here interviews no let's the some of the
advertising here
the [ __ ] did my brain just go all right
candid everybody
smile you're on candid camera
all right candid uh are you unhappy with
your smile
you don't have to be you crooked tooth
son of a [ __ ]
uh thousands of people can you bite the
back off a zebra
you don't have to have teeth like that
thousands of people have used
candid the clear comfortable removable
and practically invisible aligners
to help straighten their teeth and now
they love their smile
and candid is here to help straighten
your teeth so you can fall in love with
your smile too
number one your treatment is prescribed
and closely monitored remotely
by a license closely monitored remotely
is like something george carlin could do
like 20 minutes on
closely monitored remotely uh by a
licensed orthodontist who has an expert
who's an expert in tooth movement
tell me this guy isn't out there
crushing us at the singles bar
and what do you do big boy oh i'm an
expert in tooth movement
hello uh you'll have the same quality of
care you'd get from an in-office
orthodontist
from the comfort and convenience of your
own home and while other companies
those other people use general dentists
candid only works with orthodontists i
mean there you go there you go do you
want a handyman to
to re-fucking wire your house or do you
want an electrician
okay they're going to the pros the
specialists the orthodontist
with candid the same orthodontist who
created your plan
is is with you from start to finish so
you never have to wonder how you're
doing
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before then
and it costs thousands less than
traditional braces
uh become your best you this is the time
to do it during a pandemic
um start straightening your teeth today
right now
you can save seven and five dollars on
canvas
starter kit go to candid co
charlie oscar uh dot com
slash bur and use the code bur b-u-r-r
that's candid co.com
code burr take advantage of this limited
time offer to save seven and five
dollars on your static kit candid
candidco.com
code bur all right oh
look who's here look who's here it's old
zip uh
uh the wnba should use zip recruiter to
get some [ __ ] female fans coming to
the game
um it's finally a new year a time to
reassess your business goals for 2021
and determine
the resources you'll need to achieve
them that's where
ziprecruiter.com comes in when you post
a job on zip
it gets sent out to over 100 top job
sites with one clip
then zip recruiters matching technology
scans thousands of resumes and profiles
to send you
the most qualified people for your job
if you're
really if you if you're really
interested in a candidate
you can even invite them to apply for
your job
with one click from zip
sends them an email from you and you
stand out
from the competition it's so affected
that four to five
employers who post on zip
uh get a quality candidate through
through the site within the first day
and right now you can try zip recruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com
that ziprecruiter.com just go to
zip okay spell it out cip
re r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r dot com slash burp
all right what do we got left here oh my
book yeah how the [ __ ] you doing
i went three and one against the spread
my bookie
too much of anything is bad but too much
sports
is barely enough uh i i 100
agree with that you can't watch enough
sports unless your kids are over in the
corner crying but dad you said you'd
play with me then you've watched too
much
uh with that in mind say hello to
january 2021 from an expanded nfl
playoffs
and the bcs national championship game
to the return of the nba and nhl
this is truly a great month to be a
sports fan i always tell people
to head over to my bookie how the [ __ ]
you doing if they want to add a little
excitement to the sports they love
and the games they bet um
i don't use my bookie because some
corporate overload overlord told me to
i use them because they're the best
they'll hook you up with fifty percent
deposit bonus up to five
thousand uh up to a thousand bucks sorry
fifty percent let me read that again
fifty percent deposit bonus
up to a thousand bucks when you sign up
and they'll keep the good times rolling
with giveaways free bets and huge
contests all year long
it's simple sign up enter promo code
burr and get your deposit match halfway
up to a thousand bucks
head over to my bookie today and start
off on the right foot uh this year bet
with the best
bet with my bookie oh geez i didn't even
talk about the bruins i watched so much
sports
um i had a great time hockey is back
brad marshawn
brad marchand i guess he had a sports
hernia of course he has a sports hernia
what is he gonna have a [ __ ] uh
podcast hernia
the man plays sports for a living scored
two goals in the first [ __ ] game
uh the second game we beat new jersey
the first game lost the second game
and i didn't realize that the canadian
all the canadian teams are just playing
each other
we're not going to play the [ __ ] habs
this year unless it happens in the
playoffs
which is really weird but i am very
happy for all canadian fans of hockey
up there in the nhl for the first time
ever
first time ever you're going to get to
watch a whole hockey season
and only have to listen to one national
anthem how [ __ ] great is that because
i think secretly as much as we try to
respect each other as countries when a
canadian team plays an american team
yeah god i got to sit through two of
these [ __ ] things um
all right oh [ __ ] you know what the
great andrew themlist told me how to
pronounce this next one here
hang on one second how about miller man
having that nice [ __ ] fight to start
off the goddamn year
and how about that kid on new jersey
just being like all right i did that
[ __ ] we're playing back-to-back games i
guess i have to fight you
right who's that other kid who's that
guy number 44 in new jersey too
miles something miles wood how the [ __ ]
that guy's on the third line is beyond
me
that guy was just everywhere those two
games
great [ __ ] player um where is andrew
all right here we go
damn it i lost it all right viomi that's
how i'm going to say it v-o me v-i-o-m-e
v-o ome helps you take control your
health so you can improve your energy
gut health and boost your immune system
how does it work
test what what are your body cells
actually doing oh test what
your body slash cells are actually doing
body cells so dumb all right give you
complete
they give you a complete nutrition plan
creates your custom supplement
i.e bills personal one a day one a day
vitamin one a day vitamin i thought it
was like one a
instead of two a one egg one a day
vitamin
with only the ingredients he needs as
his specific doses based on his tests
cut out all the [ __ ] he doesn't need or
that that could be hurting him it's the
perfect supplement i've been meaning to
[ __ ] do this
i have the kid at home i want to do this
this seems like the easiest way to stay
in shape
all of those stupid thing that mirror
mirror on the wall all of those
ellipticals all of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] all it's doing is blowing
out your goddamn joints if you [ __ ]
know what you're supposed to be eating
okay you could you know you could skip
around your house and i think you'd be
in shape
all right viomi has partnered with the
mayo clinic united
health and kaiser and is used by olympic
gold medalists and elite professional
athletes
vyomi will tell will tell uh how
specific foods affect you
you may be eating too much or not enough
or what your body
needs vomi's phone application lets you
get these answers on demand questions
about food just check the app
go to vyomi.com to get your unique
insights to better health and wellness
use the promo code burr
to save 55 off your first plan purchase
this is the best discount anywhere uh
this is the special for bill
look at this i'm i'm doing it this week
all right
i'm doing it this week i'm absolutely
100 doing and of course we can't forget
my favorite
my favorite [ __ ] advertiser out there
herb
cider dot com award-winning hard cider
produced by tim herb
alexander drummer of primus made from
organic apples gluten free all ciders
have low to no sugar
you can follow them on instagram at herb
cider h-e-r-b-s-c-i-d-e-r
order online and get it delivered right
now to your door
uh you don't even have to have your
goddamn pants on to do it
right come on next weekend when you're
living in a cold city
right you can sit down and watch some
nfl football drinking a nice herb cider
all right
that's it let's get back to the podcast
here my wife's gonna kill me because i
got up late
and i said i'd only do half the podcast
and then the other half of my daughter's
sleeping but i'm on a [ __ ] roll man
and i can't stop
all right um the iraq
war mando scene what is this here
well wait i wanted to talk about a
couple other things first
before this guy starts [ __ ] on my
[ __ ] boston accent my acting
uh what the [ __ ] is with facebook
messenger
why am i still on facebook go because
i'm a 52 year old white guy
i s all of a sudden i i click on i can't
get my [ __ ] messages i got to sign up
for this other thing you know if anybody
out there
is trying to message me through facebook
it ain't [ __ ] happening i'm not gonna
see it anymore because i'm not doing the
next level of these guys i'm done with
these guys
all right um by the way it's martin
luther king day
all right one of the greatest americans
of all time and i know people try to
[ __ ] on because evidently he got a lot
of side puss but that doesn't bother me
the guy's message still i still agree
with it
um so i'm going to take my kid to the
grocery store
today or one of these days here this
week because i got to make my daughter a
birthday cake
she wants a vanilla cake so i found this
one this uh
this vanilla confetti cake that i'm
gonna make that has all these sprinkles
in it and [ __ ]
it's my favorite thing to do for her
birthday is i make her a birthday cake
from scratch
and then what's great is i get to eat
cake all week and uh i gotta be honest
with you i actually like cake better
than pie
all right not to step on sal and joe
derosa's toes with their wonderful
podcasts have you seen their podcast
uh what is it called taste buds
you gotta check that out whenever i see
a clip of that show
i can't believe how much passion i have
for food it has me yelling
at my [ __ ] cell phone screen
just going like you know joe derosa
actually said that he liked
they were arguing an ice cream sandwich
versus one of those uh what do you call
those things the uh
the ice cream cookie sandwich the
chocolate chip cookie ice cream sandwich
and at first i was sitting there going
like there's no contest you gotta go
with the chocolate chip [ __ ] cookie
with the ice cream i still believe that
but then i started thinking back
i got a lot of child sense memory with
the ice cream sandwiches and i got to
tell you something
joe derosa advertises if you're
listening actually made me go out
because of what he said and i went out
and i bought a [ __ ] box of the ice
cream sandwiches
and i got to tell you that that's one of
the few ones where it might be a draw
although the chocolate chip one is
better tasting as an adult
this i just have so many they they
didn't have that when i was a kid or at
least we never got them so i got a lot
of child sense memory with the ice cream
sandwich all right that's enough taste
buds check it out
um i think that's it yeah okay so let's
uh let's let's get to some of the reads
here
um all right i uh
iraq slash mandoscene
all right hi bill first i'd like to say
that i'm glad i finally decided to check
out your podcast a couple months ago oh
thank you for doing that
it's been my go-to podcast ever since
and has gotten me through
lots of long nights at work i'll try to
keep this
next part short as i'm sure you're sick
of hearing this already
but your performance in season two of
the mandalorian was nothing short of
amazing i
i'll never get sick of that as a
comedian to have anybody compliment my
acting and it's [ __ ] amazing
um i really felt the pain of mayfeld
during the table scene because i
served as infantry in the iraq war
during 2006
and needless to say those were some
interesting times jesus christ
i can't imagine going out on patrol and
every time you take a step you're
thinking am i going to lose my leg
uh right before we deployed to iraq my
platoon got a new platoon leader
lt whatever that means and this guy was
a piece of work
he was all about god and country to the
point that if george w
asked him to beat his pregnant wife to
death the only question from him would
be
if he could use his bare hands or use a
crowbar
jesus christ during the deployment our
fearless leader decided to dissipate
disobey an order to stay off a road that
was deemed too dangerous to travel on
needless to say this action resulted in
the meaningless death
of one of my friends during an ied
explosion
of course the piece of cockslime lt
survived well did he get court-martialed
or did you guys not say anything ever
since that day and
even up until now i dream of just being
able to waste that piece of [ __ ]
and i could just read that feeling in
mayfield's face during the table scene
wow dude i mean if i knew this story i
would have channeled that
um
i was just thinking how much i hated
going to summer school that was my
motivation
kidding sorry i have to do something
light this up this is [ __ ] heavy
email here uh my hat's off to you for
nailing that scene and believe me when i
say that you deserve
more than an emmy for that performance
wow
i wish you and the family i swear to god
people i didn't write this i wish you
and
all the family the best i wish you and
the family all the best and i look
forward to your future podcast
and to hopefully see more of your
performances in the mandalorian in the
future well thank you so much
uh very happy that you got back
safe from being over there in iraq and
um
yeah man i can't imagine all of that
all of that i just i just can't [ __ ]
imagine
just going out going okay i'm on patrol
here we go every single [ __ ] day
what that would do to you um
unbelief why the [ __ ] would he go down
that road he was on some john wayne [ __ ]
not realizing it wasn't a movie i have
so many questions about that if you want
to write back what the [ __ ] did this
jerk off say after you got a guy killed
what a [ __ ]
there has been guys like that i remember
uh
i remember said douglas macarthur was
saying that they used to call him blood
and guts
and they were they were like his guts
are blood right was that in a movie or
something like that
that was allegedly taken from actual
soldiers accountability uh
accounts anyways i don't know
[ __ ] uh all right let's try to get back
to some a little lighter here but
i definitely i don't mind if the the
reeds are heavy here
it doesn't bother me all right um i just
gotta figure out how i can [ __ ] flip
the pancake back to uh
old dumb freckles here all right uh
basquiat
slash basquiat is that how you said
yeah i've done that with my french
studies you don't pronounce the t unless
there's an e after it
art world um i'm learning so much french
and whenever like when i'm on the spot
say something in french i'm like i don't
know what to say
but i can understand it a lot better all
right hi bill
oh by the way somebody recommended me to
see this this dutch movie called another
round
check it out another round i highly
recommend it
um and it's actually a really cool movie
that is a guy you can enjoy
and if you watch it with your girlfriend
and your wife they can enjoy it too it's
just a really really good movie
uh something in it for everybody what if
you're trans
can i enjoy everybody can enjoy it
what if you're a furby or whatever those
[ __ ] people are uh oh by the way did
you guys see that [ __ ] dude man
freaking dude man that that white guy
they took off the plane on delta because
he was one of the people that stormed
the [ __ ] capital
they got he won't let me on the plane
they say i'm a [ __ ]
terrorist you are
you are a [ __ ] terrorist
you [ __ ] stormed the capital
there was a cop beating to death people
[ __ ] died
i mean what i don't know if you watched
60 minutes last night and they broke
down because i've yet to watch it
because it was so [ __ ] disgusting i
couldn't even i couldn't even watch the
[ __ ] thing
um all this [ __ ] that was going on
on that that goddamn thing and um i have
a question for all these people out
there
there's this weird combination there's a
weird thing that people are just sort of
cherry-picking what they choose to
believe
and uh i run into these [ __ ] people
that just don't want to wear a mask
and they got all these [ __ ]
conspiracies about what the government's
doing
with uh you know
[ __ ] you know uh uh um the the
vaccine
you know the banker they all this all
this conspiracy theory
against the government and they don't
trust the government when it comes to
this [ __ ]
yet they're all like support the troops
and blah blah blah blah blah
so it's like okay so you don't support
them giving you a vaccine
but you support our our foreign policy
you're supporting
where they send the troops because
that's the confusion
i always had with support the troops
it's like well obviously i support the
home team
they're defending me but just because of
that
doesn't mean i can't question where
they're sending the troops
right am i allowed to do that
it's like i support the cleveland browns
yesterday i do not support the fact
that they didn't run the ball in the
first half as much as they should have
doesn't mean i wasn't rooting for the
browns
right don't support the browns i'm just
bringing up
a question and i have a lot of questions
with why the [ __ ]
we're still over there putting the
troops that i support in harm's [ __ ]
way
all right if you've ever had the
opportunity
to drive a [ __ ] tesla
it has made the gas combustion engine
completely obsolete
and not only that which is a good thing
because
we get all that oil from over there we
would buy
less oil and i would think that we have
enough oil to run machines and all the
other [ __ ] that we need
and we could get the [ __ ] out of there
and i i honestly believe the second we
pulled out
it would be like when russia pulled out
of europe when russia pulled out of
europe
it wasn't like all of eastern europe
unified and then tried to take part of
russia
they didn't they went back to their
fights that they were fighting
before the russians were there so i
believe
we pulled out of the middle east they
were just they've been fighting for
thousands of [ __ ] years
as much as we've been there for 20 years
that is literally a blip on the [ __ ]
radar to them
they would go back to their old [ __ ]
fights
so i don't know i don't know i
i support the troops i support bringing
them [ __ ] home
and keeping them safe so they don't have
to [ __ ] have any more experiences
like that [ __ ]
first
first uh email that i got
okay and just because i say it that way
if you don't agree with me doesn't mean
you have to get angry and scream and
yell at me
you can just make your point well bill
you know i believe you know 9 11 and
i can listen to that and i'll be
open-minded and you can easily sway me
back
but for the love of god with the [ __ ]
screaming and yelling
that's going on right now and this is
coming from me all right anyway uh
basquiat art world hi bill i'm a long
time listener
who is currently trying to establish
himself in the art world
your comments on the [ __ ] in the
documentary
price of everything could not have been
more on point
bam look at that every once in a while i
am right
as it is the most disgusting and shallow
[ __ ] that rule the art market
similarly to you my introduction to the
art world began with
uh jean-michel basquiay hope i said that
right
and i began interpreting his paintings
in my own way if you or the lovely nia
like his work i strongly encourage you
to check out
uh sai twombly or is it
tombly or is it wombly i never
understand which one i'm supposed to
make silent i bet
the w silent i'll say tombly cy is his
first name
t-w-o-m-b-l-y is the second one
or frederick oh boy
this is a danish last name my apologies
to frederick here
uh it's the capital n
and then that letter with the a and the
e look like siamese twins
b i e r and then the o with the line
through it which i remember is the empty
set
from my math days or
basically a line through saying you
can't do it and the last letter is d
danish guy uh best thank you
ps if you have some space on your walls
feel free to check out
my stuff uh
you know i'll give this guy a shout out
at victor
a u v-i-c-t-o-r-w-g-r-a-u-v-e at v i c t
o r
victor w g r a u check out his [ __ ]
all right all right um
self-induce e.d from jerking it too much
oh yeah oh yeah
all right uh self-induced e.d from
jerking it too much oh what watching
like porn or something hey bill buzzkill
i'm a 22 year old guy whose dick doesn't
work now it is and you can you can come
back
come on you can make a comeback uh to
keep things short oh no pun intended
uh i've been single for a good chunk of
my life it wasn't for lack of trying
i'm just not very good with the ladies
this in turn
led me to jerking off to satiate my more
primal desires i've been jerking it
since i was 14 about eight years
and never saw any problem with it flash
forward to about a year ago
i met the most beautiful girl we hit it
off right away she and i started dating
soon after
and i've been dating and i've been
dating for about a year now the sex is
great but i've started to notice
i don't have much sensitivity below the
belt anymore i did some research
and i put and i apparently gave myself
e.d from jerking it too much well i
thought that means your dick doesn't go
up
the easiest solution is to stop but
after eight years of jerking it
it's kind of like asking a dog to stop
licking it's nuts
i want to stop because i want to be a
better boyfriend for my girl
and i wanted to know that i can get rid
of this but i've tried multiple times
and it failed each time
do you have any sure fire fire ways to
quit vices you were addicted to
i'd love to hear them i hope you and
your family are doing well in these
unusual times i wish i got to see you
when you came to texas but
it but it was but was in university at
the time maybe next time
thanks for all the laughs and go [ __ ]
yourself uh yeah you know what i would
do just go talk to a uh
a therapist he'll get you right out of
that
he or she whoever you go to we'll get
you right the [ __ ] out of that that's
not a big deal and that's so so common
um i went to a period i watched so much
porn
that the only way i could bust a nut was
through jerking off
so then i just had to not do it for a
couple weeks and then
then i was fine again with my girlfriend
at the time so that that happens
that's why you got to watch out for
porno dude that [ __ ]
is like you know and then also like
you just start going down these [ __ ]
rabbit holes like everybody like
i remember back in the day back in the
vhs days of porno right you'd get a
[ __ ] porno tape
and there was always something in there
where you're like oh my god that is
that is amazing like that's what i'm
jerking off to and then there'd be
something on the tape like oh my god
that's too far that's disgusting
if you kept the tape long enough and
watched it long enough then that thing
that used to get you off didn't get you
off
then you had to go to the next [ __ ]
level so um
i think there's going to be a bunch of
[ __ ] studies that
are going to become way more mainstream
about how bad
porno is not to mention the people that
are in it
i don't want to take away anybody's
livelihood but like you know
there's been documentaries about what
has happened to people
you know both male and female what
happened to them as kids
that makes them go into that industry so
the whole thing is just uh
it's it's just not something good i'm
just assuming that you're jerking off to
[ __ ] porn but um
i i would you know what i would do i
would openly discuss it
with you your girlfriend and just tell
her 100 and just say listen i need to
get help
because i love you and i want to i want
to get through this just get it all out
on the table now that it's all out on
the table
you know women women [ __ ] love
helping the guy out that they're with
they're really great when it comes to
that [ __ ] you just got to tell them
what's going on what they hate
is when you [ __ ] get all moody and
cause you're holding your [ __ ] in just
tell her what's up go get a therapist
[ __ ] work it out i would literally
tell say listen i'm trying to stop
jerking off i can't i need help
there's nothing wrong with that and
you're not the only person that's had
that [ __ ] problem so
you'll be fine all right girlfriend turn
stalker
you'll be fine just get help reach out
to the people around you okay
girlfriend turn stalker hi bill my
ex-girlfriend has a personality disorder
and ran out of her meds while in another
country during covent
borders were closed uh it was a small
town
in peru and she should sorry dude i'm
i gotta re-read this because uh
i've been in this situation long long
time ago all right my girlfriend has a
personality disorder and ran out of her
meds while in another country
during covet borders were closed it was
a small oh my god
it was a small town in peru and she
couldn't get access to what she needed
to keep her stable
to feel better she's been abusing street
drugs oh no and drugs she could get from
the local vegetarian
like ketamine the [ __ ] is that
a common animal tranquility oh
veterinarian
i'm an idiot i'm like vegetarian what
the [ __ ] vegetarians have drugs
sorry people veterinarian like ketamine
common animal tranquilizer long story
short after she got back to the states
she began using other drugs and i
ended the relationship she wants to
still be
together to put it mildly since then i
have gotten at least 20 calls
a day from her i've tried several
different strategies i've tried to be
her friend
that doesn't work with stalkers i tried
to say if she works on herself we can
reassess things in a year
that was a mistake yeah you're giving
her hope i tried to say don't ever call
me again and i want nothing to do with
you i blocked her number that works
and she gets an app and calls me from
proxy numbers
with area codes from where she knows i
lived
dude you have to stop answering your
phone unless it's somebody you recognize
trying to in uh
insinuate herself back in my life i
think you mean insert herself back into
her life
i block a number and she has another in
two minutes
it is infinite at this point why don't
you change your number
at this point i'm absolutely ghosting
her and she still calls at least 10
times a day
on block numbers which are impossible to
block at this point based on
my google search wisdom i'm at an
impasse i want to
to be compassionate for this human being
dude this is above your pay grade this
person needs
professional health but i don't want it
to affect my daughter
have you ever had a person like this in
your life what would you do this is what
i would do i would get a new phone
number
uh this is tough dude i would get
professional help because if you get a
new phone number does that mean that she
then will show up to your house does she
know where you live
um if you have the funds which i know is
difficult during these times
i would move
and then i would get a new [ __ ] phone
number
if you can pull off both of those um in
the meantime i just wouldn't answer my
phone unless
it comes in as something that you
recognize and if it's important enough
somebody will leave a message um
um i don't i would talk to a cop i would
talk to people that know way more than
some jerk off doing a podcast what you
do because
at least this doesn't seem like she's
done anything violent but that's what i
would be worried about
for you and especially your daughter so
um
[Music]
i don't know with my situation i just
i just had to change my number and do
all of that
i'm not gonna get into that stuff that's
scary [ __ ]
all right sir sergio leone
movies dear billy the squid
is that cause squids are red are you
just saying i'm ugly i don't even know
um anyway
billy the squid i gotta wrap this up
soon here
uh dear billy squid did you know that
once upon a time in the west was a big
influence on breaking bad
no i did not vince gilligan and the
other writers were huge fans of it
you can see the influence and all the
wide shots out in the desert
this there is even a reference to the
squeaky windmill in one episode when
mike collects money in the middle of
nowhere
oh that's so cool sergio leone only
directed seven movies he's best known
for the dollars trilogy with clint
eastwood but i would also recommend
fist a fistful of dynamite aka
duck you sucker with rod steiger and
james coburn i'm all over that i'm
watching that tonight
his last film was once upon a time in
america i've seen that with robert de
niro james wood joes pesci
and jennifer connolly in her first role
he spent over 10 years trying to get it
made and turned down
and offered to direct the godfather so
you can make it it's about an old jewish
new york gangster looking back with
regret on his criminal youth
if you watch it make sure you get the
251 minute
extended director's cut which martin
scorsese helped to restore
wow okay i know it's long but it has an
intermission built in so you could watch
it over two nights
it might be on itunes i saw it on
blu-ray but
i don't think you have a player the 139
minute
cut that they originally came out
butchered the film
yeah cause i didn't want to say it i
didn't enjoy that film didn't even make
sense and got bad reviews so
make sure you don't watch that version
okay cool uh it's only years later when
the longer version came out that it
became
appreciated as a masterpiece there is
also a 229 minute one but the 251
version is the closest to his true
vision it's tragic horrifying and
masterfully directed
with the great and uh
and nino moricone
score uh there are a lot of great
classic films that aren't screaming
anywhere
and are only available on dvd or blu-ray
so it might be a bit harder to find
obscure stuff on youtube i bet the
criterion channel has it anyways thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself
hey thanks for the recommendation that's
great all right last thing here
overrated underrated
marrying a gamer hey there oh billy
goats gruff
uh your comment on the 111 podcast
inspired me to write in about this i
love that my wife and i
share gaming as a hobby i know people
say
you should have separate interests but
getting to spend an hour or two
a day every day gaming with my wife is a
fantastic experience i got to tell you
something
that sounds fun as hell um i'd have a
lot of fun playing video games with my
wife but we
i don't know if we have the time uh
we're in our thirties
have no kids or plan to have kids i had
a vasectomy and she had a
bilateral salpingiodectomy wow i don't
know what the [ __ ] that is aka her
fallopian tubes removed
all right well let's say you solve that
problem uh we have the money and time to
devote to a hobby that brings us closer
together
the biggest arguments we have are when
she can't follow my [ __ ] directions
when we're traveling the map on map
on a quest best to you and nia and your
kids
well there you go that sounds you guys
sound like a fun couple well enjoy your
video games
um all right that's it i gotta run here
today enjoy uh
enjoy your day off if you got one um
that is it
and uh thank you everybody that wrote in
go [ __ ] yourselves and i will check in
on you
on uh thursday um
anything else yet go bruins we have the
islanders next
and um i think that's it
me and paul verzi are doing our first
episode of the new podcast
anything better uh that's it i'll talk
to you thursday